The joe rogan experience.
I'm not, you know, I don't,
I don't spend a lot of time with,
with other water unless there,
there were those who were deeply
admire who I see every now and again,
like Sebastian younger. Um, but I'm not, I
don't, I don't hang out with them day in,
day out. So there's levels
to the involvement. Yeah.
To weather how deeply you're
immersed. And it's, it's,
it's completely upside down
in the state because the TV,
new Gen TV news journalists aren't
deeply involved and just want to get that
quick shot of them looking like they're
somewhere Middle East and he closest to
the front line with the flak jacket on
the perfectly ironed shirt and they're
not, they're not sweating or even worse.
The Brian Williams type situation. Yeah,
yeah.
Or on the roof of the five star hotel.
Sometimes you might see people report
about what's happening with Isis and
they're in Beirut.
Right.
And I think they're relying on the fact
that a lot of people don't understand
that's a different country.
Um, but you know, those guys,
some of those guys are paid millions
and treated very, very well.
The photographers and print journalists
who are immersed and last spending weeks
there,
I sometimes struggling to make a living
and aren't well known and aren't well
supported.
What is it about the talking head in
front of the camera that we want so badly?
I mean I think it's, it's, it's a way
for the news networks to, to, you know,
claim credibility and then
when you see them get deployed,
they're not focused on getting material
from the war in these countries.
They're focused on the,
on the two way, right?
[inaudible] shark guy from wherever.
Right.
That's more important than actually
spending days collecting footage of what's
actually going on.
It seems like you see that rarely if
ever these days it's more and more rare.
It, it seemed to me that
during like Desert Storm, um,
in the 90s there was always someone that
was over there and it seemed like there
was real threat and it
was really going on.
But now everything seems to be done from
the desk and you don't really see a lot
of, I mean, am I right about that?
Yeah. I mean, I think emotional,
a lot of the major news
networks said to their crews,
you're not allowed to spend
the night in Mosul. You know,
you can go there and film a street,
interview some refugees who
just escaped isis territory,
but you can't spend days on end there.
Whereas the freelance photographers
and some of the writers,
they were spending days on end there
and getting, getting the real stuff.
Is it because the on camera
people will be targeted? Um,
I just think the risk is too high,
full stop for the entire crew.
And certainly if you know,
when a story is really big and you
send one of the very well known
correspondence there, then yeah, they
can't be running around, you know,
filming house to house fighting.
So when you're over there and you see
these guys show up and you know that
they're just going to be hanging out
with the hotel and what does that feel in
like, uh, yeah, I mean, I'm
pretty disdainful of those. Yeah.
Those guys you have to be, yeah.
Yeah. You see these films like, um,
whiskey, tango, Foxtrot about
Afghanistan and I just, yeah,
I just don't recognize that that world,
you know,
partying every night at whatever
bar or restaurant. I just,
I just think if you're there and you're
obviously in the wrong place, right,
right. And it's not, it's
not an adventure, you know,
it's not a fun trip for you of,
of wild times and you know, it's,
it shouldn't be that. It
should be, um, I mean from,
it feels like an endurance
test every time you go.
It should be hard and you should be
spending time with the people you're
covering. And you know, sometimes you can,
you can think you're finished with
someone and just go for dinner or tea.
And just by having normal
human conversations,
you find out so much other stuff that
you didn't go there to report. You know,
that's, that's, that's what you have
to be doing. And that takes weeks,
weeks of getting closer to them and gain
their trust. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And just,
just, just, you know, spending
enough time there where you,
you then end up being in the right place
at the right time to show something
really happening.
Yeah.
It was unfortunate that I had to take
that from him and I kind of, in a sense,
I felt like I was taken away
from what he was doing for them.
So when I saw her walking backstage, I
just couldn't control it. I just let,
I just let go and I just can help
but cry on her shoulders. Disagree.
It's a great video. What is her name was
woman's actresses. Roma Downey. Yeah,
that's her right there.
The video is amazing cause she's
hugging you and she's Talon you.
Congratulations.
And she's telling you that they're coming,
they're going to be coming
for you. So train hard. Yeah.
And it's just like her attitude, man.
It's beautiful, man. It's, it's, um,
it's amazing her character that she
handled that. I mean, this is her baby.
Her baby just lost and lost every
round and it was a, you know,
pretty dominant victory by you and for
her to treat you that way afterwards to
shows amazing character. Yeah.
And it's, Sarah is right here.
You can see it up here. Look at her.
She just embraces you. Open arms.
It's all good. It's all
good baby. Look at that.
Oh,
amazing.
That's an amazing woman right there.
He bought work a couple of phone calls.
So you take it too. Oh good. Wow.
That's amazing man. And even Tyron, the
way tire and here, it's crazy, right?
It makes me cry. Something in the
air over here. I've got to do it.
I got it made me cry when I saw it.
It's making me cry now. Yeah, man. Um,
and in the way she treated tire into the
same thing. I mean, she's just, that's,
and that, that's, that's kind
of, that's how my mom is to that.
So I felt such a connection to that to
her because my mom has the exact same
way. My mom would have done the same
thing to Tyron. And um, it just,
it was powerful, man. It was
moving. And because it's,
and it goes through a test to how the
sport has, how bay this sport is as well.
Yeah. Like it's not all man,
that's just a regular fight.
You guys hate each other and
you were fighting. No, this
was a competition. Yeah.
You know, this was two men that went in
there too for a competition and one guy,
one and you know,
and you saw the aftermath is see
the family receive each other. Yeah.
People loved that man. They
love when people put all
that bullshit aside. I mean,
you guys had a lot of trash talk at the
press conferences and there was a lot of
that going on,
but that tickets and
it's good for everybody and it's, it's
natural and normal. But after it was over,
it was nothing but respect.
Can I, can I pause here?
Leptin is produced where? Yeah,
Leptin is produced. Yeah. Let's
talk about linkedin a little bit.
It's produced in fat cells,
um,
and it's produced in proportion
to the size of fat tissue.
So the amount of body fat you have,
the more fat you have,
the more Leptin you have in the
circulation. And basically what this is,
it's what's called a
negative feedback loop,
which is a really simple engineering
term that works like a thermostat.
So with your Thermostat,
you uh,
if you set your thermostat to 70,
if it starts getting a little bit hotter,
your ac turns on to bring it back
down at the starts getting lower,
ac comes on or the heat
comes on to bring it up.
That's called a negative feedback system
and it maintains the stability of the
temperature of your house.
We have many negative feedback loops
in the human body to regulate body
temperature, to regulate blood pressure,
to regulate all sorts of things.
One of the negative feedback loops we
have regulates body fatness and the
hormones. So your, your
thermostat measures temperature
by using a thermostat,
a Saria,
a thermometer,
your brain measures body fatness using
this hormone leptin that's in the
circulation. And then particularly
when your body fat level drops,
your Leptin levels drop and your brain
hears that and it kicks in a starvation
response basically.
And this is the main reason why weight
loss is so difficult because your brain
is like, no, I don't want to be
losing fat. And it makes you hungrier.
It increases your cravings at a
certain level of body fat as a sub. Um,
so here's is just when you're
losing body fat in general,
like even if you're a large
person that's overweight, correct.
When you're losing body fat in general,
your body, it exacerbates your hunger.
And this is,
this is the thing that's really important
to understand about obesity is that
people with obesity
have a higher set point.
So it's like turning your thermostat from
70 to 80 and then your thermostats and
regulating around 80 people with obesity,
they're not regulating
around one 70 anymore.
They're regulating around two 50 and
so when you cause a lean person to lose
weight,
you see the same thing is when you cause
a person with obesity to lose weight,
you see this reaction in their brain
circuits that regulate body fatness that
drives them to increase their cravings
and their hunger to metabolic rate drops.
So it'd be an evolutionary mechanism
to force you to seek food. Correct.
And not just the foresee to seek food,
that's the main thing.
But it also slows your metabolic rate,
does everything it can to get more energy
in your body and have less leaving.
And it keeps doing that until the fat
comes back. Can I pause here? Yeah.
So when you're eating a sugary
diet, a high, high calorie diet,
you will produce more fat. Your
body will get fatter, right?
It depends on how many calories
you're eating. If you're overeating,
you consuming a lot of sugar,
a lot of carbohydrates, your
body will get fatter. Correct.
So your body will produce more Leptin.
Correct. So it comes from the Diet.
Um, yeah. Indirectly.
Definitely not. Yeah.
Yeah. Pause please. Yeah. I played the
nine holes of golf with him. Was it like,
and uh, it was, well,
there's still security
secret service all around it.
And so it was a private golf course.
Uh,
Larry Ellison a that
owns oracle. Oh Wow. Uh,
owns this private golf course.
It has 14, he's a big tennis guy,
so he puts on the tennis stuff out in
palm springs and nobody plays his course
and he doesn't play golf. And uh, Eh,
it's just his practice is to deal
[inaudible] course get is. Yeah,
he's got his own courses.
He played through our group and
shadow creek and Beverly Hill,
I mean in, in Vegas. It really exclusive
course, impossible to get on. And,
and he was playing by himself and
he was gone the tee box and I said,
as lonely at the top area. He goes, yeah.
And his ball and went off by himself.
And uh, but he wasn't even there but,
but Clinton was,
and he told me a story goes,
his friend of his as a record producer,
rap records big.
I didn't tell me who it was and didn't
tell me who the artist was either.
But the artists was all dug down and
he was in a Ferrari store and, and uh,
and uh, the salesman, he goes, are
you thinking about buying this car?
And the guy goes, no, I'm going to
buy the car. I'm thinking about pussy.
So the Glen told me a story that
had the word [inaudible] in it.
And Clinton Clinton told me that.
That's a great fucking story.
Yeah.
So, so Nietzsche and Schopenhauer talked
about the idea that there's the well,
right? So as a human being, you're
stuck in this fucking, I got to eat,
I've got to fuck,
I got to sleep and I got to breed and
I eat and I sleep and I fucked so I can
breathe, you know, and I can stay
alive. And then my, you know,
further my gene pool and you're stuck in
this kind of like will to live theirs.
But there is a response. And
that respite is, is when you,
when you see a great work of art
or you're doing great works of art.
And somehow when you see
something beautiful, when
you're laughing, really hard,
equate standard, when you're seeing them
an amazing movie like American beauty,
the state it puts you in is so
incredible because it gets you to forget
momentarily about your own biology,
about your own urges, your own needs,
your own wants for whatever reason you,
you rest in this state of majesty,
this sort of high relief, this your
higher self. And you go, you go man,
that might be what God's about.
And that might be what it's like to be
touching something bigger than myself or
bigger than all of this other appetite
stuff. Like I, it's almost like, um,
it's almost like something you,
you forget that you forget about death
and you forget about your fears and
everything else.
You know,
that those feelings of inspiration that
can happen when you're listening to
great music or it can happen
when you're making great music.
But that is almost the only time you have.
Um,
I guess,
and of course we can talk about flow
and you're climbing a mountain with no
ropes or whatever it might be.
I think that puts you in those
states of true focus and true flow.
And, um, that's what we stay
alive for. We stay alive for that.
And when you are not that,
you know,
everything else becomes drudgery
almost because everything becomes,
and I would even, I would even
equate like, oh, we stay alive also,
not just for our accomplishments,
but like when you're with your friends,
like when we're doing the fight companion
and we're laughing and being silly
game for no other reason. There is a flow
to that. Oh yeah. There's a, there's a,
you are, you are removed for
temporarily from the world, from,
from, from the reality of your
own limitations. And there,
there's something that's
so beautiful about that.
I think Nietzsche talked
about the idea that you can,
you can actually make your life that
your life should be a work of art,
live dangerously and leave a good
looking corpse. Don't, don't,
don't worry about all the other things.
Okay.